Now I'm going to walk through how to
set up a collection view in Storyboard.
There are two ways to set up
table view controllers and
collection view
controllers in Storyboard.
The first way you've seen before.
You start with the regular
UIViewController like this one.
And then you drag in a table view or
a collection view.
The second option is to use
a Table View Controller like this one.
Or a Collection View Controller
like this one.
In the table views lesson,
we used option one.
Now we'll set up our Collection
View Controller using option two.
Here I've opened to
the Bond Villains in Tabs project.
But this version doesn't have
a Collection View Controller set up yet.
To access this project, switch to the
git branch in the instructor's notes.
Now open up the Bond Villains
in Tabs project so
that you can follow along with
me as I go through the steps to
add a Collection View Controller
to your project.
The first step is to drag
in a Navigation Controller.
Next, you'll want to delete the Root
View Controller that automatically
came with that Navigation Controller.
Next you'll want to drag in
a Collection View Controller, and
this item is of the class
UICollectionViewController.
Next up, Ctrl+click on that
Navigation Controller and
set its Root View Controller to be
the Collection View Controller you
just added.
Remember that we want our collection
view to show up in our tab bar.
To accomplish that, first Ctrl+click on
the Tab Bar Controller and we want to
add this second Navigation Controller
to our view controllers array.
So we can drag here from
the view controllers array, and
add that second Navigation Controller.
Next, we need to set the name of
the Collection View Controller to match
the name of the class where all our
collection view methods are implemented.
To do that we click on
the Collection View Controller and
then open up the Identity Inspector
on the right.
Here under Class, we're going to put
Villain Collection View Controller.
Of course,
when you're setting this up for
Meme Me, you're going to put sent
Memes Collection View Controller.
Next, we're going to configure
our Collection View cell.
In order to do that, let's open
up the Outline View on the left.
Here, in the outline, under
Villain Collection View Controller,
we can see the Collection View cell.
Go ahead and click on it.
We need to set the name of the cells
class to match the custom cell class
that we implemented earlier.
So up here under Class in
the Identity Inspector,
we're going to put
Villain Collection View Cell.
And when you're setting up Meme Me,
you'll type in whatever name you
used for your custom cell class.
Now, I'm just going to make this
collection view cell a little bit
bigger, and
then I'm going to drag in an image view.
Right now, I'm just dragging in
an image view for testing purposes.
I just want to be able to see the cells
so that I know I set them up correctly.
Now I need to connect an outlet
to this UI image view.
So you can see here that I've
opened up the Assistant Editor.
And we've got our
VillainCollectionViewCell.swift file
here on the right.
Now to connect the outlet,
all I do is drag from the circle
to the UIImageView in Storyboard.
Last, but not least,
we need to make sure we set the reuse
identifier for our collection view cell.
So you'll want to make sure you click
on the Collection View Cell, and
then you'll go over here to
the Attributes Inspector, and
under Identifier,
put VillainCollectionViewCell.
All right, let's run it and
see what we've got.
All right, there's our collection view
and it seems to be loading data fine.
And in the next session,
I'm going to talk about how to use the
class UICollectionView flow layout so
that you can arrange these
cells the way you want them.